-I am here with the one
and only Questlove, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-We are about to play
a game of "Pictionary."
But to do that, we're going
to need some teammates.
First, joining my team, she's
one of the best in the biz.
She's Emmy-nominated host of
"The Drew Barrymore Show."
Please welcome Drew Barrymore!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh.
Oh, you done did it.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I'm talking about.
You always know how to do it.
Come on.
-You need a teammate?
-You want a teammate?
You got one.
-You need a teammate?
-All right, all right,
all right.
We'll see. We'll see.
-Joining Questlove's team,
she's an amazing
singer-songwriter
whose new album "Crash"
is out on March 18th.
Please welcome Charli XCX!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello, how are you?
-Hi! How are you?
-How you doin'?
-Ah. Nice to see you.
Good luck to you.
We're friendly.
We're -- Right now,
we're friends.
-Right now, yes.
-Yeah.
-I'm like, "I love you both,
but I can't right now."
-We're very competitive.
Now, look.
-We got this.
-Everyone knows how
to play "Pictionary."
30 seconds on the clock,
we'll each take a turn.
Then we'll have to showdown
where both teams will draw
the same clue
at the same time,
worth double points.
May the best team win.
Charli, why don't you go first?
And we'll have a seat over here.
-You got this.
-Wow, okay, okay.
-Love that sweatshirt, bud.
-Okay.
-Three!
-Three? So confident.
-We've got -- Three people
yelled out "three."
-Better -- They got
better than we did.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Oh, okay.
Okay, okay, okay. Right.
-All right, what --
what is the category?
-The category is,
it's an object.
-An object. Okay.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-So, it's pretty broad.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty broad.
-I -- I got this. Okay.
-Okay.
-Whenever you're ready.
-All right.
Here we go, here we go.
-Let's do this.
A fish, goldfish, fish...
-Um...
-...shing pole.
-"Shing pole"?
-Fishing.
-Oh, "fishing pole."
-Fish scales.
-The shing poles.
-The shing poles are --
-Like --
-Piano?
Xylophone.
-[ Groans ]
-Oh.
[ Light laughter ]
-The first word is fish.
Cup.
Fishing pole. Goldfish.
Fries.
Filet-O-Fish!
And French fries!
McDonald's order?
[ Buzzer ]
-Aaah!
-Ohh.
-Fish fry?
-You were -- You were so close.
-Fish and chips?
-Yes!
-[ Yelling ]
-Come on!
-No, no, no, no, no.
That was good, fish and chips.
-That was good.
-Thanks, I appreciate that.
All right.
We got this, buddy.
All right. Guys, which number?
[ Audience yelling ]
Eight.
Eight?
-Eight.
-Six.
-[ Sighs ]
We -- We -- We can do this.
-Okay.
-We got this, bud.
-All right. All right.
-Yeah.
It's an object as well.
-I'm in the zone.
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
It's an object.
-Okay. Object. Got it.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
-Cup. Glass.
Milkshake. Snow globe.
Straw.
Coffee.
Jelly beans in a jar.
[ Laughter ]
Popcorn.
The air holes.
Air -- like in a --
like a -- a coffee?
It's hot. It's steaming.
It's a cup of steaming --
-Jackson Pollock.
-Holes.
The holes, the ventilation.
The thing you put in a pool --
[ Buzzer ]
Aah! [ Screams ]
[ Sad tuba notes play ]
-That is a glass of seltzer.
[ Light laughter ]
-I thought it was fizz.
Wait, a glass of seltzer?
-Ohh.
-It's all right. We're good.
Hey, we start off, both of us
take one for the team.
-All right. All right.
We're zero-zero.
-Zero-zero, zero to zero.
It's tied.
-All right.
-Brand-new game right here.
Brand-new game. We got this.
-I did not get bubbles
from that.
-All right. So what number?
[ Audience shouting ]
You know what?
No one ever chooses 10.
I'm choosing 10.
-Whoa!
I don't even know if we have an
actual clue in the number 10.
-[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
-I get really loud.
I'm sorry in advance.
I'm sorry.
I'm ready. I'm ready.
-Here we go.
-Look at Quest, left-handed --
-Love.
-Yes!
-Love, love.
Love -- Love at.
Love egg?
Love -- love -- love
-- loved one!
A loved one!
Love a-one!
What?!
Love eyeballs!
[ Laughter ]
Love one.
Love one. Love one...
-That a popular phrase,
"love eyeballs."
-Love at one.
[ Buzzer ]
I love you!
Oh, my gosh.
[ Sad tuba notes play ]
-Love --
-Love.
-At --
-At.
Oh, love at first sight!
Love at first sight!
-Yes!
Love at first sight.
-You can't draw numbers.
-I didn't!
-You can't draw
two, three, four.
You can't draw the "at" thing.
And you can't draw --
-Look, man.
-Can't draw boobs, either.
-Tariq will be here next week.
[ Laughter ]
-Get outta here.
Drew, you are up.
-Oh, God.
-I will get this.
-Sorry, sorry.
-Well, if you thought
we were in trouble before,
I feel like
I'm a much better guesser.
-We got this, bud.
-All right. All right.
-Come on, we got this.
Come on!
-I'm going to go --
[ Audience yelling ]
-Two for your birthday.
It's for your birthday.
No, you just showed it to me.
-You saw it?
-You just -- Yeah. Sorry.
[ Card clatters ]
It would've been good.
-Oh.
-Okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe?
-Um, all right.
-All right.
Okay, here we go.
We got this, we got this.
-Ready?
-Yes.
A shamrock.
Shake.
[ Yells ]
-Oh, my!
[ Cheers and applause ]
No.
-Come on!
-No!
Don't mess with us!
-Don't clap.
-Whatever.
-Wow.
-Don't clap.
-That is exactly right,
right there.
-Shamrock shake.
That was awesome, Drew.
All right, now we --
we choose who draws
for our team for the tiebreaker.
Who should draw?
I think --
-You want to do that?
-I think you should --
-You?
-Okay. Right.
-You're good. Yeah, I'm --
-We did better --
-We did better, yes.
-Okay.
All right. Okay.
-So it's Drew versus Charli.
This one is worth
a million points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Audience, which number?
You both share the same clue.
-Okay.
-Should we do five?
They're saying five.
-I hear a lot of five.
Let's do five.
-Okay.
-We'll honor the audience.
-That's right, see?
-Okay.
Let's play.
-Do it, do it.
Here, come --
-What?!
That's impossible.
-Whoa. Okay.
-Are you kidding?
-Okay. Okay. Okay.
-Okay.
-I like my
partner's confidence.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay.
-We got this.
-Sorry, okay. It's an action.
-Okay.
-Do it.
-Running. Jumping. Rolling.
Is that -- Is that a tire?
-Drum?
Donut?
-Rolling.
Uh, uh, wheel?
Oh, is it bitcoin or something?
Crypto? No.
Coin. Coin.
-Coin.
-A quarter.
Nickel. Dime.
-Bitcoin.
-Penny.
Drop the coin!
Flip the -- flipping the coin.
-Coin flip!
-Flipping the coin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Come on.
-Okay.
-Come on.
-All right.
-That is how you do it.
I think that's a thumb.
Hold on. let's just
take this off, yeah.
I don't know
if that's a thumb or not.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, here we go.
-My thanks to Drew Barrymore,
Charli XCX, Questlove.
We got that, Drew.